good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-3790
containment class safe disruption class
dark and risk class
notice special containment procedures
the door into the stairwell leading to
scp-3790 is to be padlocked at all times
and a single guard is to be posted
nearby to ensure no
individuals enter scp-3790
by order of the overseer council entry
into scp-3790
is forbidden description
scp-3790 is a structure located beneath
the abandoned port superior canning
company warehouse
in london united kingdom the only access
to this space is down a narrow stairwell
that ends in a short black door
the door is free of identifying markings
save for a small metal placard
just above the door handle that reads
scp foundation department of
abnormalities
the remainder of this file has been
locked by o5
order the interior of scp-3790
consists of several descending levels
each consisting of a hallway containing
four
doors two per side and a graded freight
elevator at the far end of the corridor
leading to the lower levels while there
is evidence of prior human activity
within scp-3790
the structure appears to have been
abandoned for a considerable amount of
time
each of the doors is a solid heavy metal
door with a sliding panel covering a
glass viewport into the dimly lit
chamber beyond the doors some of which
are rusted but otherwise undamaged have
at some point in the past
had their handles and unlocking
mechanisms removed
and have been welded shut the only
distinguishing marks on these doors
are small metal placards located just
beneath the sliding panel
these plycards usually bear what is
believed to be the designation for the
contents of the chamber
though in some cases the play cards have
been removed or are damaged
a clipboard holding a legal pad hangs on
the back of the main access door
several pages appear to have been torn
away from the pad
the front most intact piece of paper
contains a list of names
and a short note the remainder of the
pages are irrelevant
the clipboard text is as follows
think it's about time need to lock down
other sites before i go
take care one locked
two locked three locked
four unlocked five unlocked
six unlocked seven unlocked
eight unlocked nine unlocked
and ten unlocked
the elevator has access to seven levels
of the structure
no record of the scp foundation ever
having a department of abnormalities
exists no information regarding the
structure
has been located addendum 3790
one chamber contents
the following is a list of the rooms on
each floor the text on each door's
placard
and a visual description of the contents
of each chamber
if possible level one
room one placard name vivaldi
description chamber is empty aside from
a violin propped in the far
corner of the room the bow is broken on
the ground in front of it
room 2 placard name montezuma's face
description an ornate wooden chest with
gold inlays
and a large steel lock sits on a table
in the middle of the chamber
a quiet clicking sound like that of a
clock is barely audible from within the
chamber
room 3 placard name no placard
description chamber is empty
room 4 placard name play card has been
damaged and
text is unreadable description
chamber is empty long gashes over the
walls
pieces of bone are visible across the
chamber floor
level two room one placard name
ian description a thin
pale man and a straight jacket wearing a
blindfold sits in the corner of the
chamber
room 2 placard name the crying boy
description a canvas is set up in the
room
a sheet is draped over it room 3
placard name the watchers
description three vaguely humanoid
figures are huddled in a far
corner of the room looking away from the
door the fingers can be seen
shifting slightly but due to lighting
conditions within the chamber
no other details can be made out room 4
placard name no placard description
beyond the door appears to be another
dark hallway
level 3 room one placard name
the infinite cold description
the floor of the chamber is covered with
a thin layer of water
the interior of the room seems to be
considerably larger than its exterior
physical dimensions would allow
room 2 placard name sorrow
description a pedestal rests in the
middle of the chamber
four parallel lines in the dust
consistent with finger marks
imply that whatever was upon it has
recently been removed
room 3 placard name world without man
description chamber is empty
room 4 placard name adam's hatred
description a billowing indistinct black
shape is visible in the back of the room
level 4 room 1 placard name
the morning star description
a rusted sword hangs on a rack in the
back of the room
the door to the chamber feels warm
room 2 placard name
wormwood description viewport is
obscured
room 3 placard name harmonious necklace
description a simple golden necklace
hangs on a post in the back of the room
which is lit by a single tall candle the
chamber does not appear to have a floor
room 4 placard name no placard
description chamber is unlit
individuals who look into this room feel
a lingering sense of dread
afterward level five
room one placard name the heart of matt
description inside the chamber is a
single still-beating human heart
suspended from the ceiling by a wire the
interior of the chamber appears
distorted
room 2 placard name tool marks indicate
that the placard has been pried off
the word hello is scratched into the
metal where the placard should be
description sliding panel is welded shut
room 3 placard name channel 55
description a small crt television sits
in the center of the room
something is playing on the screen but a
dark cloth has been draped over the top
of it
room 4 placard name
living nightmare description
a dirty twin mattress on a simple metal
frame rests in the middle of the room
a figure is lying on the mattress with a
sheet pulled up over them
level six room one
placard name mr silence
description a tall black wooden box
rests against the back wall
it is bound in chains and locks
a bright purple w is emblazoned on its
front
in gold trim room 2
placard name the dead man's chair
description a wooden chair sits in the
far
corner of the room a faint shadow can be
seen
sitting in it which disappears
upon a second viewing room three
placard name otzi
description a layer of ice covers the
viewport and obscures visibility
a dark shape can be seen in the middle
of the room although no details can be
distinguished
room 4 black card name apollyon's crown
description a silver lock box rests on a
table in the middle of the room
notably the exterior of the door is
covered in scratch marks
as if by something trying to get into
the chamber
level seven although the opening to the
seventh level is visible through the
graded floor of the elevator
the lift mechanism appears to have been
modified and can no longer
access that floor
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
corey barker arbiter seoul
retalias karim el ashmoy
professor puffer matthew gilmore
thana matakik eric corbidge
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
king madding samurai corgis
james saba and
nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you